[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to LED live
we have an exciting show for you today
we're going to be talking about
[Music]
Aquaman it's basically
unemployed a Wanderer with no
home but now I'm a husband and a
father and I wouldn't have it any other
way oh yeah I finally got a job I'm the
king of
Atlantis you know it is bad at this as
you
think if you lead the Seven Kingdoms
will
follow I'm going to kill
[Music]
Aquaman even if I have to make a deal
with the devil to do
it free me from my pron and all my power
will be yours I'm going and destroy
everything he holds
dear wow so a lot is going on obviously
you have Aquaman but we're going to dive
right into it he has a brother that
comes into things here did he know he
had a brother no there if you go back
it's not in this movie but in the comics
he actually has to learn about his
brother becomes one of his villains that
he faces so that's actually a point
we're going to make here first Aquaman
has a mother named Atlanta she's the
queen of
Atlantis shortly after like in Georgia
Atlanta Atlanta the way it's spelled is
how all Atlanta people say it we don't
say Atlanta it's Atlanta oh
that's and she shortly after having him
with her I guess husband Tom Curry who's
a Lighthouse Keeper m
um whom we saw in the film she was
forced back to Atlantis to become the
queen who is he in the you said we saw
him in the trailer he was a Lighthouse
Keeper he was doing that dance thing
with Aquaman oh okay like martial arts
thing yeah right so anyway she was
forced into an arranged marriage back in
Atlantis after he was born and then they
had his name was Orvac the king of
Atlantis at the time and they had orm
his brother his younger half brother
so this is arm and he has a huge hate
for surface dwellers pollution
environmental um damage and practices
that pollute the sea surface dwellers
you mean humans yes okay humans so this
movie is seems like has a big push for
climate agenda or something yes like a
Captain Planet type yes very much so go
there huh
yeah we can talk about that strangely
enough though because of this he's
trying to like take over most of the
world and kill most of the surface
dwellers so he becomes known as a
villain named Ocean Master and he he
goes up against Aquaman continually in
the comics so he actually did try to
carry out taking over all of the seven
sea kingdoms which we're going to
cover and he killed fishermen kingdoms
ruler so he got locked up in their
prison this is where we're going to find
orm at this point he's been locked up
yes so does he have like a major chip on
his shoulder like yes I am the king of
Atlantis yeah that's what I figured yes
and he always tells Aquaman I they have
a clip of this but I didn't think it was
significant enough to put it in do not
call me
brother yeah but they're coming together
to work together Aquaman actually breaks
him out of the prison to join forces to
take on their villain they're going to
be
facing oh not yeah kind of I mean well
I'm going to go on a limb and say like
most
movies uh the good guy probably has a
lot to do like a lot of similarities to
Satan the bad guy has a lot of
similarities to God or Christ right
already you see the good guy has a
trident in his hand which you always see
that associated with the devil even
though he doesn't look like red with
pitchfork and all that M but he does
have that and and um and his brother who
was locked up for a long time makes me
think of Revelation when Satan's going
to be bound for a thousand years and and
released but in this
story the good guy is teaming up with
that guy and they're going to fight the
villain who's probably a lot like God
I'm assuming some way because in the
trailer he said I'm going to it showed
the bad guy and he said I'm going to
destroy everything he loves or something
which is what almost them what they said
in the Guardians of the Galaxy 3 even if
I have to make a deal with the devil
exactly has to make a deal with the
devil oh so in a lot of these like
Gnostic movies you'll
see um maybe even the good guy has some
character traits that are like
Christlike but he ends up having to team
up with the devil and or like wet Ralph
reckit Ralph was about a good guy
Carpenter in the kingdom in the sky but
by the end of the movie he had to team
up with Ralph the the devil character to
win or what to to make a happy ending in
the movie they had to fight together to
fight the king king candy so okay so
I've heard that phrase a lot deal with
the devil like I've heard it in
contemporary songs and stuff like that
so what does that even mean well you
basically give Satan your soul or your
eternity in exchange for whatever Fame
wealth but can a soul really be sold
because it belongs to Christ right
because he paid for it so is it really
just Is It soul or Allegiance you have
free will it's your free will that's
really going I think that's the the
trick of the enemy is that after you
quote unquote sell your soul you can't
change but you're never too far gone for
Christ to redeem you know so but a lot
of people think I already sold my soul
to the devil there's nothing I can do
and that's the lie that they believe
M very true
so orm has his throne when he goes into
captivity he was in love with Meera who
is becomes Aquaman's wife and queen he
has his throne taken from him he has his
advisor that totally just disowns him
and leaves him so everything just gets
transferred to Aquaman after orm gets
out of
rulership
so this is the villain they're up
against together called The Black Manta
and he has his whole problem with
Aquaman because when they met Black
Manta had his ship of pirates that he
was on there with and his father got
killed by a misfiring of a weapon
and
Aquaman refused to help him he let his
father
die um at least that's the way that the
Black Manta remembers it so he
has
discovered later in this that as we saw
I should say as we saw he discovers on
their Endeavor down to the Lost Kingdom
Under Ice they go on an expedition they
find a green Trident that he puts
together it's broken and we saw that he
put it together and he becomes possessed
by the black man guy yeah and we're
going to go there in just a minute
but he all of a sudden it becomes known
to him that there's an energy source
called orac Calcom it's kind of like
today's fossil fuels okay and he's this
green power that's green orac calcum
basically everywhere it's like nuclear
or something green glowing yeah kind of
and he takes it he finds all of these
ships that run off of It from the old
Atlantean ancient times and he starts
using them again
underwater and Builds an army basically
a fleet to take on
everyone and he is out hiding on an
island called The Devil's deep oh
interesting and it's beautiful like it
is amazing looking but it has huge like
vampire monstrous bugs that eat
people otherwise it looks amazing
so they joined forces vampire didn't
make the travel brochure I guess right
come
visit and he starts stealing this stuff
CU apparently they got wind of this in
the very beginning that orac calcum is a
toxic
energy and so they started holding them
in vaults underneath the sea Atlantis
did and put them away in vaults so they
would never be touched again Black Manta
breaks in he grabs that stuff and he's
just using it everywhere and every what
he's doing with it mainly is burning it
to uncover more of the glaciers in
Antarctica because that's where the last
Kingdom so he wants to the ice which is
what is happening now they say yes to
unleash the lost kingdom again and
uncover it I'm just listening like is
opeg regulating this stuff you know the
price yeah for
sale it's like she's it's like totally
oil right I
mean we don't want to use it anymore but
it Powers the world so right right so
this brings us that is a container of
orac Calcom that's how it's kept in
those vaults and this is what they say
about this movie when they're talking
about this this is the director he says
I think people are going to be excited
to see that this movie is quite
different from the first movie in terms
of tone it's a little bit more serious
and we're dealing with issues like
climate change we're not afraid to lean
into that in a big way because the
Aquaman comic book even way back when
has always been environmentally
conscious he's always been someone who's
fought to keep the ocean clean and it
feels more relevant in the world that
we're living in today so this movie has
something to talk about but it's still a
fun action fantasy movie so it's not
just Mindless entertainment guys there's
an agenda in there it's not always a bad
agenda I think we should take care of
the earth and keep it clean but yeah
yeah it just reminds me of the quote
from James
mctigue you can go on I'll pull it up
here I just I have my own uh thoughts
about quote unquote climate change but
even James Cameron you know he was
saying Avatar it was all about climate
change but I I had to keep that a secret
the movie was actually a trojan horse to
make the viewer let their guard down so
that I could get my agenda about climate
change in there but we we had to keep it
a secret out so we lose all our ticket
sales he said that out of his own mouth
so you know these people are telling you
that they do have
um a message that they want to put in
their movies for all those who just are
Skeptics that think it's just mindess
entertainment you guys are digging too
deep no there is a message in the
majority of movies yeah so very similar
to that James mte who directed V for
Vendetta very Gnostic film says I don't
think anyone wants to go to the cinema
to get preached at you have to evolve
the ideas some of them political some of
them personal into a film then the film
becomes like a trojan horse you push it
into the village as one thing and it
comes out another thing
yes in real life the actor went to the
UN yes but let's read what he says first
okay he said the film would expand on
Aquaman's World building have a more
serious tone and feature themes such as
climate change making it a climate
change
allegory in the end as we know he
reveals the kingdom of Atlantis to the
world above the water and forges an
alliance with the u United Nations with
a formal address announcing that he is
Aquaman call in everyone on the surface
and in the sea to put aside their
differences to take care of the planet
oh wow emphasizing coming yeah I just I
just want to point this out because we
we talk about it a lot when we look at
different movies there's there's a
common theme with so many movies it's
apocalyptic end of the world something's
coming we have to put aside all our
differences because some Global threat
whether it's Thanos UFO Invasion Astro
climate change whatever it is we have to
put aside all our differences and unite
to save the world and biblically
prophetically that is going to happen we
know that Satan is going to round up all
the militaries of the World Unite them
together to fight against the coming of
Christ so there has to be something
taking place in our world that is
uniting us whether you believe climate
change or don't or whatever something
has to unite us together on a common
good if you will because the Bible says
that we will fight against the coming of
Christ and what is that if if you're a
Believer we want Christ to come we're
not going to we're not going to be
facing the
destruction but if you're the wicked you
will think of Christ as an enemy he's
coming to destroy you and your friends
and all that because you don't believe
in him you're not on his side so this is
really a satanic agenda to bring
everybody together to try and save the
world against a big threat like this but
when it comes in a you know in a story
that sounds good like climate change and
things that's how we buy it that's the
Trojan Horse really yeah and it's all
it's all like a you know as you read
Revelation it's like a
satanic uh
Trinity you know God in the Sabbath
commandment is identified as the one
who's the creator over the heaven the
earth and the Sea right well in
Revelation you have the the dragon you
have the Beast that comes out of the
earth you have the Beast that comes out
of the Sea and the dragon where does the
dragon come from the Bible's very clear
the dragon comes from heaven right so
it's impersonating and manipulating just
like in witchcraft it's the manipul
manipulation of the spaces that God
created yeah and then idol worship is
the is worshiping the creatures that
inhabit those spaces
right so it's it's a lot more of the
same and even like with Aquaman of
course Aquaman is you're going you're
going to get to this so I shouldn't
spoil it forever yeah we'll talk about
it later yes so just to reinforce this
idea we have Screen Rant writing now in
an interview to J uh GQ Magazine mimoa
revealed some additional details for
Aquaman in the last Kingdom the actor
apparently confirmed that the movie
includes a scene where Arthur which is
his kind of pseudo name appears before
the UN assembly and delivers a chilling
speech about an imminent disaster that
threatens the world the actor also
suggested that the movie will address
the Earth's current real world situation
and the Damage being caused the planet
by humans though not explicitly stated
it seems that the concerns in question
are climate change and pollution which
have put the Earth at risk and jumping
down to here which is quite the quote
Aquaman is the most made fun of
superhero in the world but it's amazing
to be able to bring awareness of what is
happening to our planet it's not some
story that's been told over and over
it's a movie about what's happening
right now but in a fantasy world who
said the quote I think that was Jason
Mamoa himself oh imagine playing the
role of the most mocked superhero mhm he
knows it yeah do you care if you're
getting paid millions of dollars
probably not so in the let me just make
this clear in the movie Aquaman the
superhero goes to the UN and in real
life the actor goes to the UN yes okay
so this is a picture of him he also did
an appearance at a Portugal a beach in
Portugal um that's for the Life Below
water um address that he
made about climate change and everything
again but he then went the United
Nations and address them next so he is
taking this um pretty seriously and
going all over the world to fight for
the rights of the ocean this might be a
connection that most people don't
realize but we are supposedly in the age
of Aquarius or coming up on it in the in
the New Age um and so that lasts for
about
2,500 cycles of the Moon per symbol I
guess
or sign
and when you're talking about Aquarius
it means water water bear yeah water
bear and so is it any coincidence that
this movie comes out now Aquaman Age of
Aquarius and the connection that we're
going to see here is that there's a
verse in Ephesians 2:2 that talks
about the fact that Satan is the prince
of the power of the air now you might be
thinking where does air come in but this
symbol here is a fixed air sign of
aquarius so fixed air has something to
do with this all right to hear about
that here's a um a clip now when the
Bible talks about the world obviously
we're not talking about the little
planet like we see in those picture the
little blue dot we're talking about more
than just a physical Planet the
scripture is addressing more of the
spirit of the age or what we're
referring to as the Z guys The General
ated of the age okay so when I looked up
that word and all the spirit of the age
Zeitgeist and all this stuff it was also
known as the age of the air and most new
age people will associate that and age
he was just saying was uh kind of like
the climate of the culture yeah like the
mentality of the people of humanity at
that current ERA yes the trends the
Fashions the culture the tradition
everything at that time it's like
seriously being inundated with
everything that they want you to know or
that they want you to do in your life in
the air like you're just breathing it
and it's everywhere around
you so so Satan being The Prince and the
power of the air he is kind of
manipulating Humanity through
influencers and media and all these
things which are beam through the air
you think about cell phones cell phone
waves television radio all that goes to
the airwav he's a prince and the power
of the air influencing
Society so if you look up Zeitgeist it's
a German word and it means the defining
Spirit or mood of a particular period of
history as shown by the ideas and
beliefs of the time if you go further
which is kind of necessary that's where
we get the spirit of the age Zeitgeist
in German means that it's an invisible
agent or force or Damon demon as you if
you want to call it that dominating the
characteristics of a given Epoch in
world history the term is usually
associated with George WF Hegel do you
know heelan dialectic comes from from
him I'm guessing yes
so it's really interesting because the
rest of what they have to say really
here unless it's Fashions or fads really
doesn't have much to do with this but
it's I will tell you that when they say
wel toist over there it's a world spirit
that they're promoting it's this
whole I guess spirit that they want you
to take hold of in that age in that
culture and time what I think is
interesting is it said Fashions or fads
that are
prescribed that prescribe what is
considered to be acceptable or tasteful
for an era you think about the things
that are acceptable today were not at
all acceptable even 50 years ago 30
years ago even I mean it's it's changed
a lot soge must be a German
word guessing that's true yeah Zeitgeist
if that's German volksgeist and they're
both talking about spirits and
Poltergeist have to be a German
word okay so we take that another step
forward and we're actually going to read
about what the age of Aquarius means to
the new age the age it says the age of
Aquarius the age when everything becomes
unified oh wow that's what the whole
theme of the movie is about unifying
Humanity that's actually wild yes it is
in the new age we break free of
centuries of false doctrines destructive
indoctrinations absurd ideas and
children's stories about God oh
education medicine and love are we C
cycling back to the year exactly yes so
we're probably leaving an era um I don't
know what January is I mean well it
doesn't go that way it doesn't go with
the mon yeah yeah it goes with yeah okay
this is from Old Farmers Almanac and it
says um a gray age as mentioned above is
associated with the position of the
March Equinox in 2024 the location of
the sun on the March Equinox is in the
um constellation of Pisces but also on
the border of aquarius so we are slowly
moving into a new age from Pisces to
Aquarius if we continue though it says
the corrupt foundations of false Society
crumble the T this time of Crisis is not
the signal of the end of the world what
comes is not the end but the beginning W
the dream Humanity has lived for
centuries ends and we awaken to a bright
new day a bright new
way now in the age of Aquarius
everything becomes unified all our
differences all our dualities mix
together like the fragrances of a flower
shop with all the different flowers
adding their bouquet to the overall mix
until they are
inseparable each individual flower
remains distinct and individual each
one's fragrance is unique and
discernible when you come up close to it
yet join together in unity with the
others in the wonderful mixture that is
the smell of the shop our individual
worth comes from inside from what we
have inside through our development our
Evolution and what we can give to
society now our drastic differences
dissolve and we integrate into the whole
we integrate and unify with the energy
of the universe with the great Cosmic
spirit this is like the singularity
movement and when people in the new age
in the 60s and stuff were talking about
the coming of the age of Aquarius I bet
they had no
clue how possible it would be like today
we're right we're all connected you know
everybody's connected you can't really
even get out of the grid mhm and so this
is
really Satan's plan to do what he what
is prophesied you know yeah and for me
anyway it truly does speak volumes for
ecumenicism like it is
coming and they want us to all worship a
certain God or maybe a collective group
of gods but not the true God
yeah so the verse I have there is
whosoever is a friend of this world is
an enemy of God because they want you in
unity from what they're saying and what
we're seeing today individualism is I
can be like lgbtq right I can be who I
am it's just me and it's acceptable and
tolerance but in that you're all
connected as like an undertone a thread
that connects you in unity towards in
some ways and I'm just going to say it
kind of like a Reon against the Lord
yeah just a threat of that MH
so it appears that's where they're all
headed and this is why it was a like the
right time to release this film and have
this kind of message behind it I think
the thing that is that could be
confusing because I know there's always
like push back when you're in New Age to
these kind of ideas because it's like
this isn't a bad concept okay minus the
whole thing saying you know Breaking
Free from children stories about that um
but it's like coming together as one I
don't think that's a bad idea and
worshiping one God is also not I think
that is what God's original plan was
it's just unfortunately has
been there is no one God in New Age no
right like the whole Cod exactly so you
can't really worship one God I mean you
can say okay let's worship the universe
but it's like you know it's just I just
always found it to be very confusing and
there is really no
Unity um it's
just because if you're all different all
you're doing is just being together and
like you're basically just accepting
everyone's differences right but I there
is no real like we stand on one firm you
know because even like with the lgbtq
stuff I mean there's so much controversy
with even people in the lgbtq plus
Community saying what is going on with
all these pronouns we do not agree with
this and you know it's just like
everybody's on their own page everyone
has their own truth their own reality
and there's no you know when you give
when you give like too much autonomy in
that way where people can just decide
what world they want to live in how do
you bring everyone together right
mentally like you can be together in a
physical place and like oh let's recycle
but mentally there I don't know if if
that's possible when you fuel this kind
of diversity I guess in a way that's
like not true I think we live in a
ABC culture where it's anything but
Christianity I mean you can go to
somebody and be like hey I just want to
let everybody know I become a Buddhist
oh wow good for you that that's cool and
then I'm I'm new age oh that's
interesting whatever I'm a Christian
what you know all of a sudden there's
like you bigot like Christian for real
you could say you become anything you
know I I started drinking oh good for
you you know anything it there's nothing
that's bad unless you're a Christian
yeah and so I feel like the world can
accept you as anything like oh cool
that's good for you but if you're a
Christian then that's and that's that's
the thing you know if uh when Jesus said
if if you're not with me you're against
me or something along those lines and
that's that's really how it is you're
really you're you're friend of the world
or and is an enemy of God right yeah to
play off what you were saying though the
unity is just a counterfeit for what God
is really trying to do with the entire
Human family yes yeah you know in in
Eden everyone was unified until the
serpent came on the scene and disunified
the relationship between God and man and
God has been trying to get back to that
ever since and so yeah it sounds like a
good thing everybody should be one it's
Jesus prayer in John 17 that they may be
one right you as I am one and you you
know
so that's but but the the unity all has
to be based in the right theological
premise yes once it's based in the wrong
theological premise you can't be unified
in that right we can't be there's all
kinds of unity I mean there's there's
all kinds of uh people that have been
unified against God that doesn't make it
Unity good right so it's not Unity
itself it's unity in it's what are they
unified in yeah right right yeah exactly
it matters a
lot and for us just that we take hold of
this message when we're talking about
this particular Topic in the movie we
see that we need to actually be citizens
of Heaven not of the world like they're
calling us to kind of unify with the
world and for that we have two verses
behold how good and how pleasant it is
for the Brethren to dwell together Unity
Psalm 133:
1 and there's also but be ye doers of
the word and not hearers only deceiving
your own selves for if any be a hearer
of the word and not a doer he is like
unto a man beholding his natural face in
a glass for he beholdeth himself and
goeth his way and straight way forget
what manner of man he was so right here
they're telling you you have to be Bible
Keepers or you keep the word of God if
you just hear it and you don't do it
that's the unity like that's the
separation for one but that's the unity
we're called to In Christ
amen
so to continue though there's an
interesting time when we figure out how
did Atlantis get under the sea they call
this in the movie The Great Fall when
you look it up on fandom or DC Comics
it's also called the Great Deluge the
great flood so we're going to look at
that isn't Atlantis also based on a is
that a real City underwater I there
probably some people who believe that I
feel like growing up I've seen on
History Channel or something there was
this huge
FAS there was
just with the lost the lost city of like
Atlantis so I have a clip for this we're
going to it's kind of like the beginning
story of
Atlantis
I already got one of
those not like this one you don't this
is the Lost Trident of atlan oh I know
the story it's more than a story it's
real it was forged by the greatest
weapon Masters in history crafted from
PID and steel for King atlin the first
ruler of Atlantis Legend says the
Trident was imbued with the power to
command the sea so what happened to it
to know that is to go back to the time
before the great fall when King atlan
ruled over all that
was when the kingdoms of Atlantis were
one it was a time of great prosperity
and technological advancement we had
unlocked the secret of unlimited energy
at a time when the rest of the world
still thought the Earth was
flattened but we became too ambitious
too hungry for
[Music]
power
ban swallowed us and Atlantis
[Music]
sank but the very power that collapsed
our civilization also paved the way to
our future it gave us the ability to
breathe
underwater and so we
evolved others regressed and the king
lived out the remainder of his days in
self-imposed
Exile nether he nor the trident we're
ever seen
again okay that's the fossil fuels will
get you sink you down but then you
evolve break it down for us I heard them
say posidon yes so they aren't hiding
the mythological Gods aspect of this you
know I thought Aquaman was like just a
superhero but they are throwing in the
gods aspect yeah so the Trident this is
where we also get to the origins of the
Trident because the bad guy has a
trident and the good guy has a trident M
so the bad guy has the green glowing or
a calom powered demon possessed pule
field Trident yes and then you have this
guy Tesla Trident yeah you've got like
the atan he's King atlan of Atlantis um
who started all of this he's got it
forged out of the metal of Poseidon or
the steel of Poseidon okay um and still
did you hear it was a time of great
advancement and prosperity and all that
stuff exactly so but you became they
became greedy with it too powerful and
then they sunk down into the sea so in
some ways you have of course the
flood they were going kind of like this
Tower of Babylon you know trying to get
up to the sky in heaven doing their own
thing and they were very rich and well
off and everything's going well
and it's kind of like
the the way that he's going about things
it's almost the Church of Le oia in
Revelation as well we're going to get
into that more the kingdoms as well
that's where we're going with this so
Atlantis is kind of like the advanced
Kingdom that fell into the sea as we
just saw that's pretty amazing like it
was the best out of all of them and
people are they're they're actually
contrasting it with the seven churches
of Revelation as though it is the leody
deia interesting um when I contrasted
them as we will see later I didn't see
much of the other kingdoms lining up
with the other churches I think
collectively they're kind of showing um
all of the leody disan attitude yeah and
result that occurred but you have the
fishermen and that's the evolution
they're talking about is you got half
fish half
man so you got the Seven Kingdoms one of
them is amazing and just humans that
evolved underwater in Atlantis with
superpowers to swim under the sea
communicate with the fish um almost
telepathically and all this stuff you
have them the fishermen who are just
half fish half human so becoming half
fish and half man is considered
Evolution yes oh okay I'd rather stay a
human I think Y and then you have a
deserters so that
that Kingdom of course is no longer
underwater because it became dried up in
the Sahara Desert it is lost and gone um
not to be confused with the lost kingdom
though but then you have zebel where me
mea is from and it is a penal colony
made up of Atlantean Exiles surrounded
by a magical barrier in the Bermuda
Triangle so basically you have cons you
know XC and everyone there they're the
rebels yeah me just like in Star Wars
the rebels were the good guys fighting
against the empire y here you have the
good guy of the movie right that's his
wife is is from the zebel uh Kingdom mhm
so the good guys are the rebels mhm who
were were they kicked out of Atlantis
some of them were others just left
Exiles yeah it's kind like vanished wow
y interesting you have the brine they
all turned into crab like things okay
and the
trench much of what you would find there
they all evolved into the scary glowing
monsters underneath the sea that you'd
see in a submarine but they are in the
Mariana Trench
area um the lost kingdom was the one
we're talking about the story moves on
further but they lost their power and
were frozen underneath the glaciers of
Antarctica that's the one they're trying
to uncover that black Sant wants so much
because it holds this power wait the
city the lost kingdom the city is frozen
he's trying to thow it out under the
glaciers okay yes it's like the opposite
of
hell Frozen place so this is where blood
magic yeah so there's this magic we're
going to come to find out the surrounded
around um the green evil Trident and how
it got that power and these are two
brothers I'm just going to say this is
atlan and this is almost the god figure
this is the two original forces of power
that seemed to exist in the story of
Aquarius at least in this movie and he's
almost like the good guy this is his
brother again this brother kind of thing
going on who got turned into a skeleton
for reasons we'll figure out later and
he became possessed by that spirit the
demon Spirit after he corrupted himself
almost with power so then that's Satan
more or less just think it's interesting
um for him to be the god figure and the
dark figure is his brother because what
that does in the mind is it puts them on
equal playing field that they're the
same when really God is above like it'd
be more accurate to say okay not
accurate to say son because only Jesus
is God's son but you know just something
that's not yeah we came from the same
place and we're on the same territory no
that is a good point cuz I I thought of
that recently it's like we think of like
it's God versus the devil yeah he's not
the opposite but it's not God is like M
and Satan's like this he's an angel is
an angel he's not he's not yeah he's not
opposite of God he's not's opposite of a
good Angel yeah I was reading a series
of books for my kids kind of about this
it was like like a allegory kind of like
Pilgrim's
Progress going through like this great
controversy type theme and it gets up to
the the last book the last battle and
it's the most anticlimactic thing ever
because God is so powerful and the devil
just has nothing mhm you're kind of
here's the great battle war and like yep
doesn't really happen you're done right
but it's like when you have movies like
this that is just saturating our culture
then you don't get to discern that you
know because it's like
I mean God is not the kind of God who's
like flashy and like oh yeah look at me
like you have all of this and so it's
like I don't know this is just what
people subconsciously go around
believing and I believe that for a long
time too opposite of God is Satan and
God has no opposite he's just God well
isn't I mean I think I've heard it
before there's a religion that actually
believes that they're Brothers right
well the Mormons believe Jesus and Satan
are brother
mhm okay so let's just watch this and
see what
happens oh looks family friendly yeah um
so this is the Black Manta and he's just
consumed by this demon but so the
original powers that be I guess in here
is atlan the good guy the king whose
brother is the bad guy and the Trident
started with them and were handed down
the good Trident to Atlanta Aquaman's
mother and then to him and the bad one
got lost in the
sea that is a li house burning is that
you said you said Aquaman's dad was a
light housekeeper yes just makes me
think I don't know if I'm reaching I'll
admit maybe it's a reach but uhuh Satan
being the light bearer Lucifer the
lightbearer he's the ligh
housekeeper interesting
yeah
so what happened here is that atan
started he was the first ruler of
Atlantis the good Power of Atlantis and
he had his brother cordax cordax cordax
it comes out of nowhere as I don't know
and he just like Satan is like consumed
with
power and starts corrupting himself and
because atlan sees this he puts a blood
curse and they have a clip in the the
film I couldn't grab it but of him
cutting his hand and actually chanting
and this spell chains chains cordax to
his throne and then the ice begins to
form over the entire Kingdom W and his
army so before that happens though just
before they get covered in ice
took over the world so it's bad for the
polar caps to melt yeah that's what the
Morales the zombies and the aliens M all
right and before we get there just in
case it doesn't get brought up the
point is that now this Blood curse this
magic that's been spoken on this trident
and on the city of the last
Kingdom with the curse of the you know
the blood that was spilled can only be
done by the heir to the throne of
Atlantis at that
time so we have to keep that in mind as
it goes on because it gets
darker and this is where we're going so
that's kind of a picture depicting what
happened of him cutting himself in the
whole city freezing over while atland
got out in time to not deal with that
the Black Manta in the movie gets a hold
of Aquaman's son he goes in yes wants
the blood
totally goes in there kidnaps him takes
him to the last
City and is going to sacrifice him on
this altar Before the Throne of cordax
to unleash the
curse so we got that's kid-friendly yep
right in there are there any biblical
parallels going on here like this guy is
he the bad guy like a parallel to Christ
is he the one that's doing something
with the blood or what's going on oh no
all you got to do do is Spill the blood
so he's just cuz it's a baby I'm
assuming or whatever you know most
stories they just go straight for a stab
so that's what he's doing he's about to
stab him through just to to Spill The
Blood On The Altar for this curse to be
um released okay oh that's a baby it is
oh yes
so that's the details of that obviously
that doesn't happen Aquaman shows up you
know on the scene with his brother and
his wife shows up to and who's the baby
is it Aquaman's baby mhm okay
yep okay so here's where we get into
breaking down the gods of Aquaman and a
quote from one of the writers know
Superman is Zeus Batman is Hades Aquaman
is Neptune and they kind of fit into the
the pantheon of gods of a lot of
different cultures y so the like one of
the writers themselves is just openly
telling you that Aquaman is Neptune yes
so you know this comes to a verse we've
talked about before uh I'm not sure if
it's in like Exodus but where God says
make no mention of other God's names
like he's so he's trying to protect us
so much from falling into
idolatry and worshiping other gods which
is breaking you know second commandment
bowing down to images and things have no
other gods before me jealous I'd even
ask
yeah and but yet we we are watching
these movies reading these Comics that
glorify and glamorize false gods like
Neptune and just repackage them and call
them
Aquaman yeah there's this idea that Paul
talks about in the New Testament it's in
1 Corinthians 10:20 he says rather the
things with the Gentiles sacrificed they
sacrific to demons and not to God and I
do not want you to have fellowship with
demons that's actually an old idea Paul
didn't just come up with that out of the
blue it comes from Deuteronomy where it
says they sacrificed to Demons not to
God to gods they did not know to New
Gods new arrivals that your fathers did
not fear so you're saying there's only
one God any other quote unquote gods are
really demons in Disguise so now you
repackage those false gods Neptune as
Aquaman he's a demon literally yeah and
and you know you think about what were
they sacrif I saying all kinds of things
sometimes even their children you know
it's like oh well the the gods you know
require this well God is like no I know
what that is that's a demon that's
requiring that that's not me and it's
not an idol and other places of course
he makes it clear that that Idols they
don't speak they don't hear they don't
it's okay to eat meat that was offered
Idols because they're really nothing
remember I'm saying that so what what do
you think keeps um keeps a person drawn
to that then right right because it's
like there has to be some real
experience
that keeps you on a path of deception so
it's like you could sacrifice your child
but if nothing happens then you just
think what why did I just sacrifice my
child demons are powerful Satan offered
Jesus all the kingdoms of the world just
bow to me and he he said I'll give you
uh all the
kingdoms basically anything he's the God
of this world a lot of stories that you
read about people who have been involved
in idol worship in you know like it's
this tribal thing or cultural thing
they're generally kept there by fear
right because they're told for
Generations by the witch doctor or
whoever you know if unless you do this
you know you're going to bring a curse
on you and your family and there's going
to be all these bad things and so they
never want to experience the bad things
right so they just always do the things
that they're told to do yeah right and I
believe that when you're not walking
with God and you're walking in the world
or deceived or whatever you could have
ailments caused by Satan and demons and
so now you have I don't know uh
something wrong with your body and
you've been trying everything to get rid
of it and then you go see some raiki
dude and he heals you M because Satan's
like oh if I remove this ailment now
they'll believe that there's power in
this raiki healer so now they're totally
sold out for a new age because it healed
me and that's how Satan can put an
ailment on you remove that ailment to
make you believe that this is working I
was reading a story of um rsara family
to my kids and I found it very
interesting that their family had been
involved in ancestral worship um in
Madagascar like many gener ations back
but it wasn't in some ways they were
even protected and they knew they were
protected they were um what did it say
they were told to stay away from certain
foods like certain Meats to keep their
bodies healthy and that information was
given like to the witch doctor or
whatever you know down you know down
generationally because they were to be
Servants of these you know these gods or
these
um whatever you want to call them and so
they they' kind of given them Insider
information to keep them at a certain
level so it's not always bad sometimes I
C it you know dangled
wow all right so to break it down
further as we've seen already it is
indeed Neptune's Trident that Aquaman
holds it is Neptune is Aquaman or
Aquaman is Neptune the crossover is
there um
just to make my point the Trident of
Neptune began with atland so we can see
that connection back to the original
Ancient King of
Atlantis um we have this God and the
name is Sula I guess sua Sula okay and
it says that I'm just going to read
this
Shilo brother of King Orin the first of
Poseidon POS poseidonas how do I say
that I that's okay was one of her
priests Orin incurred sula's wrath when
he insulted her by
building a protective Dome around
poseidonas W cutting the city off from
the heavens and by extension from Sula
herself It is believed that suula was
responsible for bringing the meteor to
Earth that caused the Great
that ultimately sank Atlantis wow this
is the Gnostic
plot um in the in the story of Genesis
where you have the Tower of Babel being
built they were trying to raise a city
so tall or a tower so tall that they
wouldn't they couldn't be flooded you
know they the world was flooded they're
like well it doesn't matter if God
floods the world we're going to be above
that anyway MH which is like a parallel
to this protective Dome that's
separating them from from God they don't
want the city cut off from the heavens
um and in doing that outraged or enraged
the God and caused a
flood just like uh a parallel of God
making God a villain yeah it even says
the sky God yeah so the sky God flooded
Atlantis from her wrath because Orin
built a protective Dome over the the
city to keep God out reminds me of
Noah's Arc in the tower of Bab yeah yeah
they call her the goddess of the sky wow
mhm so here again you have more anti-god
propaganda yeah yeah it's really just
the identity of God attacked on all
sides down to like I mean it's a goddess
basically not even like God like in
terms of he or like masculine right yeah
okay the next one which is kind of
packaged in here as just
complete flowers and rainbows is his
wife Meera Aquaman's wife and she is
like some
power kind of like um Storm from X-Men
X-Men she's almost that equivalent
underwater okay and her eyes glow and
all this stuff and we saw her in a short
little clip in the beginning but she
again is from zeel the rebel type
Kingdom and with all the powers that she
has it's she's kind of like the the
witch underwater that is like a straight
up witch the way that she uses her
powers as well um she can use it at any
time she wants I didn't include this but
she also they show a clip of him getting
used to changing diapers and his son
just keeps like hitting him straight in
the mouth with urine and she one time he
gets really good and he's like he moves
out of the way right when it's about to
happen and she uses her powers to make
that dream go into his mouth again and
again and again
so not good at all but she just laughs
at that and just uses it at will that is
like witchcraft yeah you know drinking
urine and all that kind of stuff
MH
so yeah as we talked about it's just
kind of she's somehow just a
beautiful almost goddess on her
own but it's kind of
weird the zebel of course as we were
pointing out are all those who are
exiled or banished from the kingdom of
Atlantis Atlantis is kind of like a
Heavenly Kingdom right right and of
course it is like Lucifer and his Angel
like his angels that left with him and
all they're trying to do like but
they're the Rebels on Earth and yet the
rebels in the story are good guys and it
says their identity is secret and you
think of like demons are in another
Realm you can't see them and yep
everything they do is secretive and
occult and that's what the word oul
means is secret right wow the weirdest
thing about this and there's a note that
I made on that is the kingdom of zebel
has less than half the population of
Atlantis similar to there being less
Fallen Angels than Angels who stayed in
in heaven and they have animosity
towards the kingdom of Atlantis they
hate Heaven
mhm yeah which is odd if she's from that
Kingdom it makes me wonder like why is
she an Aquaman teamed up cuz he's
supposed to be the king of
Atlantis they just weirdly fell in love
I I guess yeah otherwise in the TV show
kind of Lucifer when he was dating Eve
it's like oh why interesting yeah very
interesting okay so we're going to
address the whole inner working of good
working with evil that's Duality that
seems to be popping up in a lot of shows
and movies
today just what would God say about this
we're going to see that as a last um
slide but there's a huge part of the
film one of the the closing scenes in
which orm finally turns to
Aquaman and this is what is said Aquaman
says as far as I'm concerned your debt
is paid so basically he doesn't have to
go back to to that prison oh that he was
held in at all they're going to let him
off free and he is allowed to move
between all the kingdoms as he pleases
but
undercover like they're going to fake
his death wow okay and so then he turns
to him and says thank you brother
finally he's acknowledging him as
brother and thanking
him further he says you're not as bad at
this as you think the people of Atlantis
are lucky to have you you are everything
I was not you do the right thing when
doing the wrong thing is much easier and
you are willing to ask for help even
from your worst enemy
wow
okay so yeah I mean that is a duality
thing you know it's as long as you have
a balance of Good and Evil we all have a
little good we all have a little evil as
long as you keep it balance that's good
but that's not good right
nope so
the last point that I want to end us on
is do not call what is evil good or good
evil you cannot mix the two as the word
of God says woe unto them that call evil
good and good evil that put Darkness for
light and light for Darkness they put
bitter for sweet and Sweet for
bitter yeah also adding to that it says
in first John 15 this is the message
which you have heard from him and
declare to you that God is light and in
him is no Darkness at all it's not
blending
together so it's interesting that a lot
of the culture has been duped or tricked
into thinking that evil is good because
there the artist is telling you Aquaman
is Neptune and the Bible's telling you
all all false gods are demons so Aquaman
is a demon and if you ask anybody is
Aquaman a good guy or bad guy good guy
it's now being now you have a whole
culture of people people when Batman
based off of a demon he's a good guy uh
you know people even go as far as to say
Lucifer in the show Lucifer he wasn't
really that
bad that's the point that's why the mov
that's why the show is bad because
they're making it look like the devil is
not bad right yeah and so this is the
culture we're in where where people call
evil good and good evil mhm yeah I think
it's interesting because um like I don't
think that these films are teaching
people to fight like in ter if something
does happen I think it's just preparing
people to make a decision and they'll
already have a you know a bias towards
that decision because of everything that
they have watched but I was talking to a
friend the other day and we were talking
about um in Daniel with Nebuchadnezzar
and like the statue and um just
picturing
what that looks like so it's like you
know you see the feet being built and
you know it took time to build that then
the legs and the waist and everything
and it's like that was at first glance
you would think okay this is probably
nothing to worry about maybe he's just
building a statue but it's like what at
what point do we need to see the warning
signs and just pay attention and say
okay I need to I need to make a decision
I need to prepare my heart and I think
of how many people were in that crowd
who were godb believing and said oh let
me just pretend to tie my sandals or let
me you know let me just you know bow but
I'm really going to be praying to God
and it was out of everyone in that in
that City or that nation and only three
people were like I'm going to give it
all to Christ and they had the same
amount of time as everyone else in that
City and so it's like we have to at some
point stop making excuses and just
recognize what's happening even if we
don't know the whole context and like
God tells us like what we're supposed to
be doing and what to expect and we have
to make that decision for ourselves and
we won't have any excuses it is not
anyone else's fault um but our own
that's why it's called free will we
cannot blame anyone um so yeah it's just
like in the garden you can have the
whole blame game going down but it's
like you didn't have to eat the fruit
like period you know know like that was
your choice you cannot blame anyone and
so yeah I think it's just I don't know
how many videos we need to put out on
this for the point to be made just stop
you know you just even if you don't feel
the effect I think that's also a problem
because it means desensitization and
then it's like how much further do you
need to get how much further do you need
to watch in order to realize like you
know you're you've already made the
decision basically or you're you're
putting your life your salvation at risk
just by constantly putting yourself in
it so yeah you know that's really true
we all we're all going to have to be
accountable for our own decisions and
you can't blame anybody else and really
any of this stuff if you just watch it
like you said it's desensitizing us it's
it's um twisting the character of God
and yet we're being entertained by it
you know it just breaks God's heart so
if you guys were blessed by this give it
a thumbs up and if you know anybody
that's going to go see this movie or is
just a fan of comics we got a whole lot
of videos on comic stuff we got a whole
documentary on it called the replacement
Gods you can check that out on Vimeo we
got a lot of other full length
documentaries on there that are not on
YouTube just the clips are on YouTube
but uh if you know anybody like that
share this video with them it'll help
get this video on the algorithm also if
this is your first time never seen our
Channel never seen anything like this
click the thumbs up I mean click the
Subscribe button and click the little
Bell icon so you can see new videos as
they come out we do shows like this
every week and throughout the week
There's different ways you can support
this ministry you can go to little light
studios. TV and there's a a donate
button there you can do it that way or
you can go to lightwear do shop we got a
lot of cool shirts there where you can
wear your witness and that helps our
ministry as well and we also have a new
ministry called little light kids if you
got little ones check out that uh
YouTube channel because we're putting
out content that is safe and suitable
and most of all biblically sound for
children and we will see you guys next
week bye
guys if you're looking for good
wholesome educational content for your
children subscribe to our new channel
little light kids if you're looking for
a way to spruce up your wardrobe this
year check out lightwear do shop it's a
christian-owned apparel company with the
belief that we are all walking
Billboards one of the best ways to share
your Witness is to wear your witness
these conversation starter designs are
the perfect way to look good while
shining your light for Christ for a
limited time use promo code love for 15%
off your entire order that's 15% off for
new clothing for you and maybe a gift
for someone special so go to lightwear
do shop and remember use promo code
[Music]
love
a